the U.S has announced another 325
million dollars in military aid for
Ukraine as the Ukrainian military
continues its counter-offensive the
eight includes more armored vehicles
Russia without offering any evidence
claims it has destroyed 25 to 30 percent
of Ukraine's foreign supplied Hardware
Ian Lee reports from Southern Ukraine
a dusty road leads to one of the latest
Villages liberated by Ukrainian troops
no building is left untouched the trail
of Destruction shows the ferocity of the
fighting several hundred people lived
here before the war now it's a ghost
town
this Soldier says the village was under
Russian occupation for a year and a half
these are Ukrainian lands
and this is a symbol of their Victory
fluttering in the Wind
but it didn't come easily bodies of
Russian soldiers lay nearby abandoned by
their comrades this cell phone video
shows a damaged Ukrainian armored
vehicle more will be needed on Tuesday
Russian President Vladimir Putin's
boasted to journalists his forces have
destroyed 25 to 30 percent of foreign
supplied equipment while on the same day
the Pentagon announced a new 325 million
dollar Aid package in terms of this
package this is something that meets the
priorities of the ukrainians
um armor artillery air defense these are
all priorities that they've laid out
part of the package includes Striker and
Bradley armored fighting vehicles but
the air defenses are also desperately
needed for a second night Russian
missile struck a Ukrainian City
targeting a business center and
Warehouse in Odessa the country waking
up to more civilians killed as the war
drags on for CBS morning's Ian Lee in
southern Ukraine